>> Sean: THE MEDIUM AND IT IS
A MOM OUT NOW COMPLETELY
UNHINGED.
THEY ARE ONLY GETTING WORSE.
GOES FOR HOLLYWOOD TO BE A LOOK
AT THE UNIVERSAL PICTURE IS SET
TO RELEASE A NEW MOVIE ABOUT
HUNTING IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES
FIRST BOARD MEETING ON, WE
SMELLY TRUMP WALMART VOTERS THAT
CLING TO OUR GUNS, GOD,
RELIGION, AND BIBLES.
WELL, NOW THE MOVIE HAS BEEN
PULLED.
MEANWHILE, JUST LAST WEEK YOU
HAD THE PSYCHOS OF CONSPIRACY
TV, THIS TIME, COLE WALLACE
CLAIMING THAT THE PRESIDENT
CALLED FOR THE EXTERMINATION OF
LATINOS.
DON'T EXPECT A REAL APOLOGY FROM
ANYBODY OVER THERE.
THIS IS PRETTY MUCH EVERY SECOND
MINUTE AND HOUR OF THEIR DAY AS
THEY FOLLOW CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, THE BEST OF THEM ALL,
ROSS MEL RACHEL.
WON'T BE APOLOGIES.
THEY JUST MAKE UP THE NEXT
CONSPIRACY.
HERE AND I WAS REACTION, THE
HEALTH, JOE CONCHA VARIABLE, I
DON'T EXPECT THEM TO EVER ADMIT
THEY'RE WRONG.
I DON'T EXPECT THEM TO OWN IT.
I DON'T EXPECT THEM TO CHANGE
WHERE THEY ARE WHO THEY ARE AND
I THINK NOW THEY HAVE KIND OF
BEEN EXPOSED AND THE PRESIDENT
HAS DONE A GOOD JOB OF TATTOOING
FAKE NEWS INTO THEIR BRANDING
AND I DON'T THINK THEY EVER GET
BEYOND IT.
>> SHOW.
WHY WERE THEY APOLOGIZE IF THERE
IS NEVER ANY ACCOUNTABILITY?
WHY WOULD YOU EVER APOLOGIZE FOR
SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
ACTUALLY ROOTING FOR A MASS
SHOOTINGS TO HAPPEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WHY WOULD JOE SCARBOROUGH EVER
APOLOGIZE FOR THROWING OUT A
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT THE
RUSSIANS SOMEHOW HAD A HAND IN
THE KILLING OF JEFFREY EPSTEIN
QUESTION MIKE WHY WOULD MSNBC
EVER APOLOGIZE FOR PUTTING ON A
FORMER FBI ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WO
FORMER FBI ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WS
FORMER FBI ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WI
FORMER FBI ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WD
FORMER FBI ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WT
FORMER FBI ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WA
THE PRESIDENT WAS ONLY
RE-RAISING FLAGS ON 88 BECAUSE
THAT'S A BAD SIGNAL TO
NEO-NAZIS?
IF THERE IS NEVER ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY, OF COURSE
NOTHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND AS FOR THE HUNTS, TRY TO
PICTURE A WORLD WHERE SUPPORTERS
OF ELIZABETH WARREN OR
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ ARE
HUNTED AND GUNNED DOWN BY
PRO-TRUMP SUPPORTERS AND THEN
TRIED TO PICTURE THE MEDIA AREA
REACTION.
THE PITCHFORKS AND TORCHES
IN-STORE WOULD RUN OUT OF THEM
AND BE ON BACKORDER FOR MONTHS
AND THE MEDIA BACK REACTION
WOULD BE APOCALYPTIC.
IT PROBABLY LINKING THAT BACK TO
THE NEXT MASS SHOOTING AND
SAYING THIS IS WHAT INCITED THAT
SAYING THIS IS WHAT INCITED THAV
SAYING THIS IS WHAT INCITED THAO
SAYING THIS IS WHAT INCITED THAE
SAYING THIS IS WHAT INCITED THAC
SAYING THIS IS WHAT INCITED THAA
SAYING THIS IS WHAT INCITED THAD
SO I THINK THE PRESIDENT
DESERVES CREDIT.
HE SAID QUOTE THE MOVIE COMING
OUT, SPEW 26, IS MADE IN ORDER
TO INFLAME AND CAUSE CHAOS.
THEY CREATE THEIR OWN VIOLENCE
AND THEN TRY TO BLAME OTHERS.
THAT IS PRECISELY RIGHTS AND
THAT IS WHY THAT MOVIE WAS
PULLED A DAY OR TWO LATER, THE
BACKLASH WAS JUST TOO
OVERWHELMING.
AT >> Sean: FOR ALL THE
CRITICISM OF DONALD TRUMP, AT TE
ROOT OF IT, THERE IS A DEEPER
ANGER AND THAT'S THAT THERE
REALLY IS A BELIEF SYSTEM THAT
WE ARE SMELLY WALMART VOTERS PEE
WE ARE SMELLY WALMART VOTERS PEA
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLE THAT --
I'M GUILTY.
I TRY TO CLING TO GOD.
BE A BETTER PERSON.
AND, BELIEVE IN A THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
BIBLE, YEAH, I BELIEVE IN THE
BIBLE AND RELIGION.
I THINK THAT'S GOOD FOR SOCIETY.
I HAPPEN TO BE A CHRISTIAN,
JUDEO-CHRISTIAN PRINCIPLES BOTH
AS CONTRIBUTE I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK IT'S INSULTING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO WORK WELL FOR THEM.
YOUR THOUGHTS WHICH MARKS TO GO
IT WILL NOT.
YOU THINK OF THE CURRENT TURNING
POINT IN 2016 WHEN
HILLARY CLINTON CALLED TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S A BASKET OF